we have some man-children
i got a baby in my head maybe a villain
bottom line just needs to stop dude and
make outs with guys named ben ben
[Music]
this is your the bachelorette season 16
episode six recap
grab your glasses it's time for
roses and rose hi everybody
it's me lauren zema and i'm
getting to know you getting to feel free
and easy getting to like you
getting to help you like me getting to
know
you oh yes anytime i have an
opportunity to make things musical i
certainly will
and this episode was all about making
the men
a musical like amusing not a musical but
amusing
i'm talking about how we're getting to
know the guys
oh babes what fun we are having i am so
excited that we're getting to know the
guys because
you know before when things were all
about veil
we didn't get to know them and now we're
having different characters come out
we're learning their stories i want to
be
a husband and a partner we're getting
some comedy
and i'm really excited to show her how
grown
my ass is some villainy he's wearing
robe and of course more bennett let's
get to
it you guys ready let's do it okay cool
let's go
we are starting off with a group date
where we are looking for a grown
ass man
ass man
is anyone else noticing that we're doing
a lot of hyphenate
ass words since tasha's arrived
last week it was she's got these big ass
eyes like you came in with your smile
and your
like big-ass eyes and now we're looking
for grown-ass men i'm looking for a
grown-ass man okay
i mean i don't have a problem with it
but i do think we could do better
and i also thought we could have done
better with our challenges
on this group date but we did do great
with our alums
ashley and jared and jared's hair are
here
one of my favorite trios don't drink for
how long jared's hair is
[Music]
that's some quarantine here everybody
take a seat so as part of this
competition to see who is the most
professional and competent adult male in
the group
grown ass man um it is faster i'll say
that it's faster to say
yes streamline ashley and jared are
introducing the challenges
and i found it challenging to see how
this would tell tasha that these guys
are grown ass men
damn i'm gonna say gam it's even faster
and then i get to stop saying
ass so tasha's looking for someone who
is smart
so we're gonna test your skills in math
and spelling today
they've literally set them up kind of in
school and of course we're reminded
that bennett went to harvard which gives
us a chance
to talk about bennett
[Music]
you know did go to harvard and i think
that is uh playing into my favor
yeah i think i'm you know in the sort of
upper echelon in terms of being a grown
ass man
at what time will you get to the date oh
but
bennett is not doing great no no no
he's struggling with time the correct
answer
is 9 17. with math
bennett got it wrong it's all right with
spelling
oh bennett forgot the u wait who would
dark
so we did all that and and now we're
testing brute strength
this is just more like middle school man
challenge
isn't it i mean if you were doing a real
gam challenge wouldn't you do things
like give them sample tax
returns to file ask them exactly what
they would plan
on a date in the real world inquire
about their 401ks
oh my gosh i love a man that can cook oh
no but now we're in homek yes we're
making breakfast
this was maybe the best part of the
challenge i hate to cook and so i do
like to see if
a gam can cook don't drink every time i
say gam
gam i'm gonna say gam gam gam can cook
damn isn't damn like an old school word
for legs i would fail this
so they're making deja breakfast in bed
i could get used to this
and everyone is trying to stand out
everyone's trying to out do
and so jason decides to do nothing
i just thought that i could be the main
course
uh for breakfast yeah jason's way of
getting noticed
was that he got shirtless and told tasha
that when it came to breakfast
he was the feast i could be the main
course
for breakfast
jason you might think you're again but
i'm going to say can you damn me some
real food because i'm hungry
okay you you guys tell me this would you
rather
a man bring himself shirtless to your
bed in the morning or
a man bring you a breakfast to your bed
in the morning i want the omelet
okay okay and a mimosa
yes oh
but then but then but
[Music]
yes bennett is having his turn and
he has shown up to this portion of our
programming
in one of my very favorite
things something that got me through the
quarantine something that's both
comforting and chic
something that feels like an escape from
the second you put it on
a fluffy white robe
yes i brought this here today get to
wear a robe at work
i'm gonna have to take it off at some
point it's very hot under the lights
next up bennett bennett
hello hello now not only did bennett
show up in a robe
but bennett made beignets
i know that you like you know donuts and
naturally
you need to have a beignet from bene
oh that was good yeah
of all the breakfast foods what would
you want someone to make you for
breakfast i would want beignets
from bennett and then
or should i say and ben knit
kissed tasha congratulations oh
we've been waiting for this so don't
drink for their whole kiss
do you guys think bennett's a good
kisser let me know in the comments below
jason did not he said that the kiss
was cringy when bennett kissed her the
whole room cringed
and i didn't understand where that was
coming from nor did i think it was fair
and of course i got very defensive of
bennett
i mean jason's even criticizing him for
wearing a robe he's like
calling him a tool that just shows that
he's classless
he has no respect for their guys he's
wearing robe
and i'm thinking jason you're shirtless
in an apron read the room
furthering my questioning of this
competition bennett won
i bennett
congratulations bennett
bennett bennett
vignette tonight i'd love to pick up
right where i left off in that bed with
keisha and you know continue on our
evening
now they go on the nighttime portion of
the group date
and jason still has a problem with
bennett wearing a robe
that kiss in there it's very very cringy
crunchy just come you're like your robe
right now buddy ah that's all right
but then it is not to be out done
bennett is going to have his fun
in bennett's mind he's already won
because he's got a martini
let's try this with rose i've never done
it we don't know what's going to happen
it'll certainly get my rose nice and
cold maybe make it a little
rose all day celestia situation
is this on oh god this is a mess waiting
to
happen
[Music]
how's that for our audio then it would
have been more refined
but you know what bennett would have
done it for me he would never have let a
lady
shake her own drink let's see
i've made it kind of cloudy
[Applause]
but you know what i'll take it because
this rope feels like sitting on a cloud
[Music]
watered down very cold though nice okay
okay i had to take the robot that was
getting too hot but this is still fun to
drink out of
something different oh but from
bennett to ben yes we are getting to
know the guys and i am glad
to be getting to know a little more
about ben
and then when it comes to tasia they are
having a little moment
and bennett goes for it and by it i mean
the kiss i'd love to kiss you
you're gorgeous oh
what did you guys think of this i loved
how he told her
i'd love to kiss you i'd love to kiss
you and then he just
went for it i felt like i was in a
hallmark movie i felt like ben was the
lumberjack or
veterinarian or coffee shop owner who
lives in the cute little vermont town
i'm tasha and after tasha a girl from
the big city from california
moved there to escape and start a new
life oh she ran into him when her car
broke down on the side of the road and
he helped her fix a tire and then before
you knew it they were
off to the races of a flirtatious banter
that would end with a kiss
like that
different show lauren different show not
really not really um
what did you think of ben and tasha's
kiss
oh but not everybody is enjoying
themselves jason and bennett are still
fighting i don't really know why but
jason
jason
actually i'll be wolverine because
that's kind of my nickname had the nerve
to say that he was gonna be
superman those guys can come at me all
they want batman and robin
i'll be superman
no bennett is superman
uh jason is fighting with ed well like
you're not here for the right intentions
you're a bad actor
you don't have a future i don't even
know if i can take you serious sometimes
but what i did love
is that ed earlier in the grown-ass man
competition
had been given the award of man-child
and he'd been given a baby
as that award
and ed is just holding on to this baby
the whole time don't drink for the whole
time that ed
is holding this baby
[Music]
i want a little danny carlos
but bennett is a grown a-man and he is
trying to move forward
so he makes a toast to being a gentleman
to being a gentleman and a grown-ass man
and you know
who refuses to raise his glass
the man who's not grown ass
chase my man i can't choose you
oh jeez chase no cheers man come on
no cheers you crossed it buddy is jason
the villain i didn't see this coming
we don't know you know we're five weeks
in but we don't really know these guys
we don't really know
that's what i'm realizing and it's
exciting me
jason's a fraud chasing the phony
luckily ed
finally kind of explained it i think
their problem with jason is they think
he's here for his career
he said that you could essentially be
using this for a career leverage
what is he they say he's a fraud jason's
a fraud chasing the phony what did he do
oh they say that he is saying the same
things to tasha
that he said to claire that i've heard
him say identical things declare that
he's been
saying about you and just kind of using
the same exact adjectives the same
verbiage
did we think this criticism of chasing
was fair bottom line
this needs to stop dude pissing me off
oh but then
ed tells jason hey man back off
i have a baby i don't know what you're
doing i got a
i baby like now that's a grown-ass man
thing to say
i wouldn't be ed i wouldn't be ch i
wouldn't do any i don't play
but then then
yes ben comes back again with some truly
grown things to say
he says the grown-ass man is somebody
who is kind
they're humble they protect those that
cannot protect themselves
and he made ceramics he made them in his
shop in the back of his house that he
built there after his wife died
he was longing for love it had been so
many years alone
after that loss and he'd been waiting
for the right person she's
beautiful couldn't be better and then
would she be
the right person as she stumbled in one
day hoping to find a gift for her mother
oh do you guys like the hallmark movies
let me know in the comments below okay
but ivan gets the rose and ivan
would you accept this room i would
definitely accept that and we are at the
rose ceremony
and ed still has that baby and jason is
still
fighting see my character has been
portrayed in a false light
and bennett is still gentlemanly yes as
the others are fighting bennett says
give me that baby he doesn't need to
hear this let me let me take carlos from
your first over here
he doesn't need to hear that okay so but
then we've got to give chase in a little
credit because
you know he says he's trying to do
better he doesn't want them to think
that he's just saying generic things to
clarentia
so he's come up with a new word
a new adjective a new sentiment
for our queen goddess angel mermaid
being of light
tasha he calls her
a smoke show and you know my new word
she's a smoke show
taser's a smoke show
i mean what woman wants to be called a
smoke show
how would you feel about that being the
one word that someone called you if they
were only going to pick one word
let me know in the comments below i'm
not saying it's bad to be called a smoke
show it's just
if that was gonna be the one thing he
had all day to think of a new adjective
and he did not think of one new
adjective he thought of a noun
he thought of smoke show
[Music]
oh that one looks good at the rose
ceremony don't drink for every little
surprise
they gave tasha joe brought her food yes
joe
demar wrote her a poem what love means
to me is seeing you smile day after day
again and again and that was nice and
bennett takes her to paris
i really can't wait to go on a little
european vacation
that's cute not bad right would you go
to paris with bennett
let juan know in the comments below
so this jason ed thing is a thing
and tasha confronts jason about getting
too physical with ed it's it's
rolling to something much bigger to the
point where it's like now
in a sense getting physical and you know
i thought about how tasha is having to
do exactly
what she did not want to do tasia said
she didn't want to have to teach
a guy how to be a man i want to grow
with someone i don't want to
like teach him how to be a man you know
but now we get to see zach having a
conversation
with atasha a real grown conversation
um zach seems really normal to me
you know i was wondering why is he here
how did he get here uh he explained it
by saying
he's here to see what's here i'm here to
uh see what's here you know what i mean
like that's
why i'm here and like smoke show this is
a smoke show
that could have been better but i like
zach what do you think
let me know in the comments below i i do
feel zack seems very grounded and i like
the conversations they're having
and speaking of mature tasha says
something i've been saying your age does
not
indicate your maturity
you could be 40 years old and still a
child
very interesting that she picked the age
40 for that
comment
think about it you know what i can't
we're gonna have to because
and also that's bennett would want
better for me bennett would have want
better for me you know
i know he would chill it a little bit
now we have more and tasia's getting
less she has her first rose ceremony
and you know to be honest she cuts some
guys who i still
don't know i'm looking
for my perfect match tasha maybe it's a
wrestling match
and now another group date before we had
grown men
and now we have some grown ladies these
women are strong
yes we are doing a wrestling group date
and i absolutely loved that they brought
in some
female fighters i am a four-time former
women's champion and a wwe hall of famer
wow
hey guys i'm tatiana suarez and i'm now
a current undefeated ufc fighter
yes cheers to that i'm really excited to
show her
how grown my ass is
as a man you know don't drink for every
guy we kind of got to know who we've
never known before
joe the anesthesiologist i mean i want
to brag here
but i was uh all-conference in
volleyball in high school
i loved him he was giving such funny
commentary uh they were kind of
trash-talking each other and he said and
i quote
jason is very thick as well
jason is very thick as well his trash
talk was
you're a really nice guy all right i
just want you to know you're a really
nice guy all right
am i in love with joe
babes hi i just had to come in with a
quick vlog to talk samoa
about joe yes am i obsessed with jonah
you guys truly i keep thinking about
this
36 years old anesthesiologist really
funny witty
calls himself a lover not a fighter is
he the only
option am i over bennett
[Music]
joe
[Music]
what's happening let me know in the
comments below
oh you guys i just thought about
something what if
claire really had the best group of guys
that's ever been on the show because
they had the most time to cast that
they've had in years for the show and so
she got this amazing group of guys and
that's why she fell in love with dale so
hard so fast
i tell i feel like i just met my husband
because she seriously had just these
unbelievable men to choose from
no that's not it that's not it but i do
really like these guys
oh and don't drink for every franchise
alum we see this episode
wells is here to help commentate thanks
for having me thank you for allowing me
to leave the bar
so now we are really going we are doing
the wrestling we are gonna get on the
mat
but first we've got to oil the men up
oh yeah i'll thank you man thank you
looking good
edition was kind of uh basting and
brushing them
like a thanksgiving turkey i don't know
was that olive oil deja said that it was
every girl's dream
this is a girl's dream honestly i don't
know if it was my dream um
to be honest it just made me want a
bread basket a little balsamic vinegar
a nice sprinkling of a himalayan salt in
there maybe some fresh parmesan
so they're all oiled up and joe goes
down quick but we do love his man bun
that's what we call a mercy kill and
jordan and brendan are going at it sweet
little brendan and tasha is like oh his
balls are in his face
these bubbles and i was like can we make
it through
one episode without a balls joke
not very groan of us
so wrestling wrestling wrestling and
then
ed uh decides to drop out at the very
last minute which i did not think was
very grown follow through on your
commitments ed
hey chris can i grab you for one second
where are you going
he says he can't physically do it which
i have no judgment for i just didn't
know why he waited until he was
shirtless and all oiled up
i got some really bad shoulders that
dislocate chronically to
tell chris harrison that i mean you know
now you got to wash that off
is there anybody here that wants to
fight flirtatious heart
but with ed out noah jumps in
and we don't really know him
but he's the guy with the mustache i
can't wait to know their names i'm very
very excited to know their names
and maybe he was living in a utah desert
town a small
town he'd stayed there since high school
and always wanted something more
and when a woman from the big city came
in
he thought this is what i'm looking for
this is the woman who will challenge me
to be better
and i can show her about what's
important in our course
why in my stories is the woman from the
big city
always
okay not that i care because sports but
jason wins the whole thing
jason and noah
gets a spot at the after party for his
boldness
you jump defense for me and were willing
to get in the ring and fight for me
i'd really like you there tonight if
you'd like to join us i'd be honored
even though he wasn't on this group date
oh and now jason is really trying hard
to make friends isn't he he puts his
wrestling belt down on the table in
front of everyone and says
we are all champions and i'm just going
to have this right here for all of us
we all we all deserve this tonight boys
they're not all
champions they're not all grown ass men
but some of them are trouble
you're in trouble i'm not nothing i'm
going i'm perfect
yes i think we've gotten a little tell
from tasha
you guys when she's really attracted to
a guy she calls him
trouble don't drink for everyone tasha
called
trouble you're in trouble he's trouble
i'm telling you
oh god he's gonna be trouble i already
know it
you know noah yes ma'am there's one
thing
you don't like mustaches so
noah whose name i now noah i i had to
learn his name because
he shaved off his mustache i'll miss you
or rather tasha did yes yes yes she said
she didn't love it
i saw that i don't like it but i wonder
what you look like without that thing
you know like what if it would be like
fun if we like shaved it off or
something
and i wanted to ask you guys what did
you think of noah's mustache
i liked it unpopular opinion i don't
know
he was a barber he'd always wanted to
study at vidal sassoon
i gotta stop okay you can't stop we just
gotta go through the whole thing
and for shaving off that thing under his
nose noah
gets the rose noah
man i barely recognize what did you
think of the roses that tasha gave out
this
episode i was having a hard time getting
a read on it and maybe i need to reset
because claire was giving us such an
easy time of getting a read
i feel like i just met my husband but
you know there was even a moment with
ben
before you give out the rose do you mind
if we go talk where he wanted to talk to
her and she said ben
you lost your chance the night's over
okay
i actually have a theory i think tasha
is playing hard to get here you guys
i think that the guys she really likes
she's making them work for it a little
bit
making him chase that rose i think when
it comes to the rose
it's actually kind of a no
what do you think let me know in the
comments below
now i'm just really digging into
conspiracy theories because everything
with clarendale was so obvious that i
want like mystery
he was a detective worn hard from
working those late nights in detroit
but tasha gives noah the rose for a date
he wasn't even on
but honestly today you really fought for
me so we know
there are still no rules in this
franchise
the only thing that everyone but me
seems to agree on is
they didn't like the mustache you look
really good without the stash do you
guys
agree
oh what an episode everyone what did you
think let me know in the comments below
we really seem to get back to our
bachelorette
timeline here and as we're getting to
know
the guys do you have any favorites
bennett but seriously do you have any
other
favorites give me your predictions let's
solve the mystery
who do you think will be in the top four
we've seen her dad saying he doesn't
like a guy she's with why him
who's that about all right everybody
thank you
so much for watching i'm lauren zema you
can find me on instagram
tick tock twitter and of course on the
app cameo if you want a personal message
from me i live tweet the show every
tuesday night and then
i see you here on roses and rose thank
you so much for watching no matter what
your story is
i love you so much and we'll see you
next week bye